so let's bring out our first guest y'all
he is a four time Super Bowl champion
and five Time pro bowler five times geez
these days you can see him as an analyst
on Fox NFL Sunday and he really let me
down this season because back in August
this is what he promised me personally
team that you'd bet money on to win the
Super Bowl oh I'm going to go with the
Dallas Cowboys and they've been making
the playoffs every year it I feel like
this is the year they just you know get
over that edge
what we all
thought what what I thought as well oh
my God I I am in love with your suit
that's my favorite color Yes Green's
your favorite color oh mine's red and
blue it is very American of you yes
thank you red and blue USA yeah um I I
used to love you till you said the
Cowboys were going to win and then look
what happened I don't understand
everybody was saying that we were going
to look we say it every year I get it
but like but I really did think like we
had had all the players it was all there
I know I I did that pick for you too k i
you look here's the thing I yelled so
hardcore I I became that crazy fan watch
I got really into football this season
I'm like into fantasy football do you
have you ever played fantasy I never
played fantasy football ever I know all
about fantasy football you don't think
about that like as a as a football
player you were like man what if these
people were all combined on one team
well you kind of had that cuz yeah I
actually knew how it worked and like
throughout the season when I was playing
I always made sure I was like okay if I
can score a touchdown there's like two
minutes left in the fourth quarter we're
already winning by like three touchdowns
but if I can somehow sneak another
touchdown in for my fantasy owners
they're going to love me that's what we
say at home just walking in and then you
start getting angry at the other players
that you don't have but it's so fun
anyway does it anger you that fans we
use the word we like we're like we lost
and like we didn't do anything like does
it you know what I'm saying actually no
it doesn't anger me at all all because
without the fans we wouldn't have the
NFL we wouldn't have good answer so it's
it's a collectivist so we make sense
okay cuz I feel insane at the end my
daughter is like why do you keep saying
we and I'm like I used to be you I know
but now I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
them thank you guys have a great night
I'm going
home